let me ask a big ridiculous question
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing we talked about
at the beginning of the conversation
about death
and the fear of it the other big
question we ask about life is its
meaning
do you think there's a meaning to our
existence here on this little
spinning ball that's uh you
you've thrown some some powerful
questions that's the most powerful
um
for most of human existence
the meaning of life was very very simple
survival the only
thing that humans cared about was just
surviving because it was so
damn difficult for the early years of
human existence on this earth
if you look at ourselves as biological
agents everything about our body is set
up for one mission
and that is survival every reflex we
have every
element of our uh structure is just
built up on the the battle to survive
and then humans did something remarkable
they elevated themselves through the use
of
technology and social structure
to the top of the food chain
so that they went from extraordinary
extremely vulnerable
if you take a a naked human being alone
and put them in the serengeti plains in
africa
they're in some deep [ __ ] okay if you
look at a human being
as a survival organism just by itself
naked
they are among the most feeble at their
task
in the entire animal kingdom
you compare us with predatory animals
we are weak and soft
and easily killed
but if you take that same human and put
them in a group and you give them basic
technology
steel a spear
a knife he goes from the bottom of the
food chain
to pretty much at the top
and so humanity found itself
in a crisis that emerged out of its own
success
for most of its history their only
interest was the battle to survive and
they
they did it i don't know how they did it
but they did it they got through ice
ages
droughts famines disease everything
and they found a way to get to the top
of the food chain
and that's where it all got interesting
because an organism whose only interest
was in survival
yeah had for the first time in their
history a more or less
guaranteed survival
and so the big question now is now what
we survived there's no more danger the
average human being
finds himself in a world now where
there's almost
zero danger from predatory animals where
getting a meal is the easiest thing ever
where getting to and from work is not
problematic at all
where the majority of infectious
diseases
medical complaints can be resolved in a
hospital
fairly easily
and so they start casting their mind
around okay
what do i do now and so
the minute mankind's
existence became more or less guaranteed
the problems shift from survival
to meaning we found ourselves grappling
with a whole new issue that had never
occurred to our ancient forefathers
but which now becomes one of the
centerpieces of our modern lives
mean when you look at your own life when
you look back
you think i did a hell of a good job
you know uh hunter s thompson has this
line that i often think about
that life should not be a journey to the
grave with the intention of
of arriving safely in a pretty and
well-preserved body
but rather to skid in roadside in a
cloud of smoke
thoroughly used up totally worn out and
loudly proclaiming wow
what a ride that's which is the complete
opposite of survival well not complete
opposite of survival but
basically embracing danger embracing
risk
going big just living life to the
fullest
so within that context
what would make you proud of a life well
lived
when you look back you john donahue
looking back at your life
first i will address that question but
let's first look at
why hunter thompson could say that
because his life was more or less
guaranteed and safe
if you look at animals in the animal
kingdom the pattern of their
life is very simple they take the least
risk possible to secure their existence
lions are powerful creatures but when
they go hunting they typically go for
the weakest animals they can kill in
order to eat because they don't want to
take the risk of injuring themselves
knowing that if they do they die so the
brute reality is
the only people who can talk about
having
casual danger in their lives are those
whose lives are guaranteed
and a fascinating small tangent hunters
thompson took his own life
so that's that seems like a deeply human
thing to suicide
yes um that's a fascinating question in
itself
if you look at the the number of
suicides per year it's a shocking
shocking statistic that gets almost no
recognition
and yes uniquely human you don't very
very few animals
you see killing themselves because the
whole thing is just survival
and that humans paradoxically when
survival is more or less guaranteed of
killing themselves in vast numbers
it's usually linked back to the idea of
meaning because
it's so hard it's it was hard
to win the battle for survival but it's
ten times harder to win the battle for
meaning
um
when i think about it first off i'll say
right from the back
there's never going to be an agreed-upon
sense of meaning there's
as i said there was one thing that our
our physical bodies agreed upon and
which is hardwired
biologically into us and that's survival
but once we got
to a more or less guaranteed survival
then all bets were off at that point
you just have to start listing your own
criteria and what one person will
describe as a meaningful life another
person will
decry as is meaningless or wasted
um
there's something terrible about the
idea that we're sitting around
you know waiting for meaning to show up
on our doorstep but what i find the best
people do is they take charge of it and
they
they look at their lives and in a form
of authorship
where they see their life as a tale
to be written and they do their best
to write that tale and put as much
control over the
the direction of this story as they can
in the end we all have to just try and
write our own story
we all have our own interests i try
to bring in the sense that even though
i'm
an atheist i don't believe that we go on
to to live after this i'm
i i believe that there's a possibility
of
a god in an afterlife i don't say it's
impossible but
in order for me to believe that they
exist i'd have to see better evidence
than i see
currently nonetheless i do believe
that there is a great value in the idea
of
living for something bigger than
yourself
the moment you see yourself as the be
all and end all of your existence you're
in for a meaningless life
and nothing will ever satisfy you you
can have all the money in the world you
can have all the power in the world
you'll be empty inside
i do believe that humans have a deep
and abiding need to follow
the interests of a group bigger than
themselves as an individual
is it ideal no is it an answer to the
meaning of life nope because eventually
that group will itself die out so
there's a sense in which it it just
plays a kind of delaying game
but i do believe that in order to live
a happy life meaning
as a central part of that and the
deepest sense of meaning
not a fully complete answer but a better
answer than most people give us to
to find something which hopefully does
very little harm to the people around
you and mostly benefits them
which enables you to become part of a
community
and to live as i said for something
larger than
than you as an individual
if there is such a thing as the perfect
conversation
it would be a conversation on
death meaning and robots
with the great john donna john i've been
a fan
it's a huge honor that you would waste
all your time today thank you so much
for talking today my pleasure thank you
links
you